just in case you didn't get enough
Pokemon news last week well we got more
also there's a vendor's gameplay we're
here to talk about it I'm Kurt Davina
this is safe state for Wednesday June
24th welcome we finally got our first
major look at Crystal Dynamics Avengers
game which shows us a central villain a
whole bunch of gameplay details and Thor
a lot of Thor so first up the bad guy is
MODOK who is this enormous head dude
with teeny-weeny arms and he's a super
scientist control robots with a giant
super-smart brain and his whole plan is
to wipe out the inhuman infection aka
superheroes second we got a look at
Kamala Khan who is on the mission to put
the Avengers back together who have been
deemed a threat to society the First
Avenger we saw official gameplay up was
Thor who's straight-up looks exactly
like Chris Hemsworth none of the other
Avengers in this game look like they're
actor counterparts except for him we
also got a look at character
customization options and skill trees
which are called tech trees where you
can upgrade how you want to play your
avenger there's really quite a lot to
unpack so you can watch the full
presentation on our channel at
youtube.com slash GameSpot or you can go
to our website to keep up-to-date and
all that jazz you know the drill there's
gonna be links in the description below
now in case they get enough Pokemon news
at last week well lucky for you there is
more in fact we're getting another game
called Pokemon unite which is a Pokemon
MOBA and it's coming to switch and
mobile it's gonna be cross play but we
don't know when is coming out yeah
Pokemon unite is gonna be 5v5 you can
pick from an array of Pokemon with their
signature unique abilities where you'll
have to work as a team to score goals at
control points however there's no
advantages to the type you use but
rather the strategy in which you play
their abilities as the game progresses
you level up evolve and get new
abilities and I'm personally pretty down
for all of these smaller scale Pokemon
games we're getting so big we have one
for helping me brush my teeth we have
one for running a cafe and now we have
one where I get to have competitive
meltdowns every single day it's a good
balance brush my teeth make lattes for
squirtle have a meltdown online with
other players I can date it okay so yeah
Zaira bunk was delayed again and then
there was the night city wire livestream
that was delayed but it's happening
tomorrow
for sure definitely you can catch the
livestream tomorrow on Thursday June
25th at 9 a.m. Pt and 12 p.m. ET and the
thing is gonna be 25 minutes long
showing us a brand new look at the game
and you can watch the stream here on
youtube.com / GameSpot speaking of which
we're gonna have a ton of coverage on
cyberpunk so just stay here stay tuned
in at GameSpot to see all that roll outs
and at least hold you over until the
game comes out officially a November
19th also just to remind you really
quickly GameSpot is doing play for all
its big fun multi weeks sweet streaming
games stuff every single day we're
having a charity stream from 12:00 p.m.
Pt to 2:00 p.m. Pt featuring a load of
guests raising money for black lives
matter and people fighting on the front
line for kovin 19 relief coming up this
week on Thursday tomorrow we have a
stream going with some of the voice
actors of Red Dead Redemption playing
Red Dead online and then on Friday we
have a charity stream with the top 5
Skyrim mods of all time with Seb and cam
and on Friday we're also gonna be
playing rocket league with Naomi Kyle
but there's a full list of the schedule
and all that jazz in the description
below we also have a bunch of exclusive
content interviews with people who
worked on the Avengers people who worked
on crash bandicoot and that's all on our
channel as well so be there to check it
out ok that's it I'm done talking I'm
done talking about news there's that a
whole bunch more gamespot.com so be sure
to check it out if you want I'm Kurt
Davina until next time see you later
[Music]
[Music]